له ملف تعريف ممتاز وأنا
أعتبر هذا اللقاح
كلقاح قريب من
الكمال وله ملف تعريف غير كامل ،
نعم لقد أجرينا تجارب ما قبل السريرية
أظهرنا أن هذا اللقاح قادر على
حماية الحيوانات
من العدوى في ظروف صعبة للغاية
تجارب التحدي
ولقد أجرينا بالطبع اختبارات أكثر
بكثير مما نشرناه حتى
الآن وهذا يوفر لنا الكثير من الثقة
مع فهم
طريقة العمل
جنبًا إلى جنب مع بيانات السلامة
الواردة من التجربة قيد التشغيل ،
نعم نعتقد  أن لدينا
منتجًا آمنًا ونعتقد أننا سنكون
قادرين على إظهار الفعالية ،
فأنت لست في عجلة من أمرنا لتقديم
هذا في السوق إما بشكل صحيح
لأنني أعني
كما قلنا أنك تعرف شيئًا
كهذا لا ينبغي أبدًا أن يكون  مستعجل
لأن الناس الآن في السياسة يتحدثون
عن نهاية أكتوبر ،
كل شيء أراه في الانتخابات الأمريكية ،
لكنكم يا رفاق تركزون فقط
على العلم ،
نعم لا يوجد شيء آخر  الطريقة التي نفكر بها
في
جميع الخيارات حول كيفية تسريع التنمية ،
لذلك قمنا على سبيل المثال
بتنفيذ
برنامج بحث على مدار 24 ساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع ، نعم أه
حقًا نضمن أننا لا
نخسر أي وقت
نتعاون معه مع
السلطات التي تساعدنا
لمراجعة مستنداتنا بما في ذلك
بيانات السلامة
في الوقت الفعلي تقريبًا لضمان
عدم ضياع الوقت
ولكننا لن نقوم بأي اختصارات ، فمن
المهم للغاية
أن يكون لدينا تطوير كامل
يلبي جميع احتياجات التطوير الصيدلاني
لضمان حصولنا على  لقاح آمن وفعال ،
هل سنتحدث عن نوع من
الموافقة على الاستخدام في حالات الطوارئ ، هل نتحدث
عن
الموافقة الكاملة على ما أعتقد بالنظر إلى أننا
قد قمنا
بمعالجة الحزمة الكاملة
المطلوبة لتطوير اللقاح
بما في ذلك
الدراسات العلمية قبل الدراسات السريرية
السلامة  اختبار التحمل واختبار الفعالية
يجب ألا يكون هناك الكثير من الوقت
بين إذن استخدام الطوارئ
والموافقة الكاملة
[موسيقى]